thank you very much to our three
co-sponsors today the the genocide
studies program the shell Center and the
Council on African Studies I also want
to give a special thanks to Jim silk and
to David Simon I spent exactly half of
the last 18 years here at Yale and both
of them have been such cherished mentors
to me so I'm so deeply grateful to both
of them thank you
today I'm gonna talk about the legacies
I'm gonna continue the conversation the
legacies of the the international
legacies of the genocide but I'm going
to focus specifically on justice and law
issues I'll start by talking a little
bit about the causes of the genocide and
how those relate to the consequences
I'll then review the the main
transitional justice mechanisms that
were instituted and then I'll talk about
the legacies of those institutions so
this is an overwhelming slide that's
meant to be thee there were so many
numerous causes of the genocide from the
racial superiority theories to
discrimination that it really plagued
the Roman society against Tutsi severe
poverty overpopulation but it really was
a single factor that that perhaps really
catalyzed the the genocide this that
there was a culture on impunity and
immunity being sort of separate things
that was born from this historically
unaddressed atrocities there had been
atrocities dating back half a century
before the the genocide of 94 even
erupted in various scholars and
officials even categorized some of these
as genocides as well especially in 1959
and 1963 there has yet to be a legal
determination that any of these events
were genocide but it's very clear that
mass atrocities been committed against
Tutsi for about 50 years in Rwanda and
so what did this lead to there you know
the official responses was that nothing
would be done to the Hutu who had been
involved in massacring the Tutsi and
only that but the there one in
government at the time even took a
further step it actually instituted very
a series of legislation legislations of
impunity to immunize the perpetrators of
these atrocities so the signals to the
Hutu extremists were twofold one was
that you could practice and even refine
your ability to kill on Moss at least
the at least the Tutsi and then the
second was that they learned that they
could commit with impunity that simply
nothing would be done if if Tutsi were
killed this then led in 94 after the
genocide Institute see the massive
genocide against the Tutsi was
perpetrated to a number of questions
should this now be a time where the
genocide air the genocide perpetrators
should finally be brought to justice and
if so how when where and who among them
some estimates were that there were
possibly as many perpetrators as victims
and if that's the case there was an
enormous number of perpetrators who very
well could be held accountable
there were essentially four main
transitional justice mechanisms that
were instituted during during and after
the genocide the conversations the
decision-making process actually started
even during the genocide so there were
two outside of Rwanda one was judicial
procedures instituted through the UN
International Criminal Tribunal for
Rwanda the ICTR
and that involved two different aspects
one was prosecutions by the tribunal
itself and the other was transfers from
the tribunal to other jurisdictions the
second main institution outside of
Rwanda were judicial procedures by
foreign countries and again there were
two elements to this one were
prosecutions that the foreign countries
themselves would implement and the
second were ex traditions or
deportations of suspects to other
jurisdictions and I'll talk more about
those in a minute
then there were two mechanisms two main
mechanisms within Rwanda itself one was
the prosecutions by the
ordinary domestic courts and the the
final one were prosecutions by gotcha
which we'll be discussing more so the
the Rwanda tribunal was established in
November of 1994 it was established by
UN resolution 955 and then a few months
later the location the seat of the
tribunal was established through
Security Council resolution 977 it was
decided it would be placed in Arusha
Tanzania the consideration was that
Rwanda itself was too unstable in the
immediate aftermath of the genocide to
to house the tribunal the outcomes to
date and this is based on the most
recent report from the tribunal are that
all trial level cases have now been
completed so there have been about a
little over 90 accused individuals for
whom trials had been completed there
have been a pellet level judgments
delivered against 46 of those
individuals the tribunals now also taken
the step of referring some of the
outstanding cases to national
jurisdictions a few to France some to
Rwanda itself itself and some fugitives
so those still have yet to be
apprehended also to Rwanda there's now
also a residual mechanism that's been
instituted for both the Yugoslavia and
the Rwanda tribunals and that's assumed
the responsibility for trying even more
cases so in some ways it's it's it's
really just a continuation of the
tribunal itself the tribunal also
withdrew a few indictments three excuse
me to some of the young died and I tease
had died either before or during their
trials and the tribunal projects that
it'll complete all of its work by July
of 2 2015 given that it was instituted
in November of 1994 that'll be 21 years
as for the foreign countries who have
been involved this has been predicated
on on basically two different mechanisms
one is a claim to universal jurisdiction
the idea that some offenses are so
heinous that any country in the world
can and should be able to bring cases
against their purpose
in their courts it's it's a
controversial claim which we'll discuss
more in a moment and then there's also
been the introduction of various laws
locally domestically that have enabled
these prosecutions so I've listed here
the ten or so countries that have
already brought cases or considering
bringing cases France is one to point
out for just a moment as lots of
suspected genocide arif sought refuge in
France and is only until very recently
that France has been willing to bring a
case against them as for the foreign
countries extraditing or deporting I
thought I would give you two examples
from our country so an extradition to
the ice-t are one example comes from
2000 where Elizabeth ontake Rita Mona
had been seeking refuge in Laredo Texas
he was the very first person who was
excavated from our country to an
international tribunal there was also
their vaults have been deportations or
they're considered deportations to
Rwanda the most recent of which is a
conviction in New Hampshire of Beatrice
minyan NZ for lying on her passport so
one of the mechanisms are the strategies
through which American the American
justice system will pursue genocide
offenders on our soil is to catch them
lying on their immigration forms that
about what they were doing before they
got here and if indeed you're you're
caught lying
there's punishment here in the United
States and then the the possibility of
extradition or deportation to Rwanda
which very well may happen in the case
of her moving on to Rwanda the there was
a recognition very early on even in the
process of setting up the ice TR that
the ice TR was never intended to process
the overwhelming you know a number of of
genocide perpetrators and so the
preamble is I note here even includes
this recognition this acknowledgement
that that part of international
cooperation should be focused on
strengthening the capacity of their
wanting courts themselves to deal with
this
huge caseload Rwanda had acceded to the
Genocide Convention which obligates its
members or its its signatories to
prosecute or punish - excuse me to
prevent and punish the crime of genocide
they'e ceded to this treaty in the 70s
but it wasn't until 96 20 years later
that legislation was introduced to
actually make them capable of of dealing
with these cases so the organic law the
relevant organic law was was introduced
in September of 96 and then the first
case was initiated a couple months later
in December now that brings us to
catracha which in many ways is the most
innovative and widespread of the
transitional justice mechanisms that
have been instituted to deal with the
Rwandan genocide
gotchya itself in Kenya Rwanda the
indigenous language means the grass or
the lawn and basically it was introduced
out of this idea that there was a
necessity to somehow deal with this
enormous number even if the STR was
going to deal with just a few dozen
maybe 70 or so in the national courts
the ordinary courts were going to deal
with a few thousand that still left
hundreds of thousands of cases still to
be done to be dealt with and so
essentially this get chacha system which
had been a traditional conflict
resolution system in rwanda was
resurrected was revived and it was
modified it was revised to deal
specifically with genocide crimes in
2001 the relevant jurist legislation was
introduced establishing these what was
known as gotcha jurisdictions and in
that at that time four categories were
established that would delineate you
know what crimes you were suspected of
and where that would then indicate you
would be prosecuted the most egregious
offenders the the real masterminds would
be dealt with through the ordinary
courts but that would leave those who
had attempted murder who had committed
property crimes thought to be dealt with
through katachi
this legislation has been modified
several times a 1:04 of six or seven oh
eight
and in part to streamline the process
and in doing so it it collapsed
categories two and three into one moved
category four de category three and left
category one to be dealt with through
the ordinary courts and now categories
two through three would be dealt with
through gotcha
one of the really amazing things about
gotcha is the number of participants in
it and so in 2001 260,000 judges were
elected locally and this represents
about 6 percent of the entire Rwandan
population at the time was elected to
oversee to participate in adjudicating
gotcha and also as part of the gotcha
process also to deal with the enormity
of the caseload the wronging government
to began provisionally releasing
detained individuals in the tens of
thousands as you can see the cachaça
process lasted exactly 10 years from 2
to 12 and I thought I would provide you
the the really staggering statistics of
how many cases have been dealt with so
it tried almost 2 million cases it
convicted 86 percent of the individuals
involved in those cases and acquitted 14
percent and then heard appeals from
about 9 percent affirming 74 percent of
them reversing 26 and then if you look
at the statistics a different way if you
look at them in terms of the suspects
instead of the cases and the reason why
you need to look at them separately is
because some individuals committed lots
of crimes so led to multiple cases and
some individuals banded together in
groups and committed individual crimes
for a single case and so if we look at
the numbers that way it tried over a
million people and most of whom the
overall majority were men so I thought I
would talk a little bit now about the
legacies that we then take from these
four transitional justice mechanisms one
at the level of Rwanda concerns the
death penalty
so President Kagame at one point says
the government could not become a max
mass executioner in order to correct
mass murders and you know the criticism
at the time in the concern was that if
indeed Rwanda follow through on capital
punishment for these genocide crimes you
would have massive death penalties and
of course there would be for a different
reason but the optics and also just the
the overall logistics were you know
greatly concerned a lot of people the
second sort of concern about the death
penalty was that this was really an
obstacle for transferring cases from the
tribunal and from foreign jurisdictions
the rules of procedure and evidence of
the Rwanda tribunal itself dictates that
cases cannot be transferred to any
jurisdictions that implement the death
penalty so the part of the legacy is
that the Rwandan government decided to
abolish the death penalty in o7 by that
time it had actually been several years
since and he definitely actually been
even carried out and in some ways this
really contributed to the overall
campaign the global campaign to abolish
the death penalty for third party states
for foreign countries there are a number
of legacies as well one is one concerns
universal jurisdiction which I mentioned
before even though it's it's a very
controversial claim legally as well as
politically some aspire to this idea
that that really when it comes to
genocide and other atrocity crimes these
these should concern us so much that
that there they really ought to be dealt
with anywhere this has been implemented
to varying degrees in different
countries and has also received a lot of
pushback for various reasons there's
also been incorporation of atrocity laws
enabling legislation in various domestic
and national jurisdictions that allows
domestic polities domestic countries
jurisdictions courts to prosecute for
atrocities and then another legacy is
that
as we know the the new now permanence
war crimes tribunal the International
Criminal Court with potentially
unlimited jurisdiction globally has been
signed by over a hundred countries all
over the world there have been other
legacies also from internationally from
the International Criminal Tribunal for
Rwanda itself so three just to point out
because there's such precedent setting
significant legacies are that the ice-t
are had the first conviction of a former
head of government in the form of Prime
Minister John Kim Banda the the second
was that it's the very first
international tribunal to define rape
and sexual violence and that it can
constitute genocide and this was in the
case of al Qaeda zoo and then also
significantly the the tribunal
determined that Mir speech which had
been such a component to both inciting
as well as orchestrating the genocide
itself Mir speech could also constitute
genocide genocide incitement and that
was in the famous media trial as for
Rwanda the recognition the legacy here
is that there is a need often even if
international mechanisms are constituted
and even if there's a domestic
infrastructure available for additional
transitional justice systems in this
case it was in the form of gotcha and
these can be done sequentially or
simultaneously alongside the other
existing transitional justice mechanisms
the scale and the significance of gotcha
cannot be understated nearly every
single Rwandan adult has been involved
in gotcha
it's now a population the country has a
population of about a million million
people this is a staggering statistic
and they've been you know involved as
judges as witnesses its defendants in
something that's led some people like my
colleague Phil Clarke to describe
katachi as the most comprehensive
post-conflict justice program program
attempted anywhere in the world and
there are very
other sites of atrocities that are
looking now to get ChaCha as a possible
model for indigenous transitional
justice as for the legacies of from the
International side the establishment the
ice-t are itself was was precedent
making it really affirmed the role and
the power the authority which had been
established during the establishment of
the the creation of the Yugoslav
tribunal the previous year of the
Security Council to create these ad hoc
tribunals but in the case of the ice-t
our this was the very first time that's
a tribunal had been created for a purely
civil conflict establishing the
precedent for even internal crimes which
relates to I think the RTP the r2p
concept it's now led also to the
proliferation of tribunals in in various
countries around the world and for
various scenarios Sierra Leone Cambodia
Iraq Lebanon and also the creation of
the the new permanent International
Criminal Court one of the things I
should point out is in in my research
this is been very evident that there's a
safe an amount of path dependence which
relates to the design and whether or not
to even create a transitional justice
mechanism in the first place the ICR
from what I can conclude was largely
created because the ICTY had recently
been created and as we look at how
weather and then how tribunals and other
transitional justice mechanisms are
created around the world it is vital to
look at what already exists and what
comes before it
in many ways they're used exactly as as
models for what comes later
some of the individual legacies that
derive from the ice-t are include that
the prosecutor there was a shared
prosecutor of the ice-t UI and the ice-t
are initially and basically the reason
was because it would been so difficult
to find a suitable candidate in the case
of the Sui that person in the form of
justice Goldstone from South Africa was
then just sort of had an expanded
mandate to include Rwanda but the
problem was that the the people who had
served in his and who later served in
his capacity in his position as chief
speeder of the shared tribunals spent
very little time focused on on Rwanda
some estimates are that in some years as
little as thirty five days were spent
actually in Arusha at the other tribe
you know this led to lots of management
problems problems and so the legacies
from that were that were included that
the the tribunal itself separated the
tribunals had separated excuse me the
Security Council separated the
prosecutor for each of the tribunals you
know three and then each subsequent
tribunal that has been created has it
has had its own prosecutor its own chief
prosecutor with a recognition that the
attention that individual can focus is
required there have been lots of
concerns and criticisms of the speed
with which the ICR has been conducting
its work I just mentioned that itself
the tribunal itself doesn't project
projects that its work will not be
completed until next year meaning that
it'll be twenty-one years and so the
concern is that you know this is is
really an unjustifiable delay in in
bringing to justice these perpetrators
now that we have a permanent ICC in part
of the rationale for even creating out
in the first place was that you would
have a standing mechanism that was able
to dispense justice a lot more quickly
avoid the the delays incurred in
starting up a new institution each time
you had an atrocity there's also been
concerns about the cost of the tribunal
it is now cost over 1 billion dollars to
run
it's an astronomical figure you know
when we think about it and so the
criticisms are that this has just been
unjustifiably expensive you know again
part of the impetus for the ICC was that
you would start consolidating cases into
a single institution and hopefully you
know reduce the cost also the hybrid
tribunals that have been created for
Sierra Leone and Cambodia have also been
designed in ways with cost in mind
more more criticisms that lead to
further legacies are that
two few cases have come before the the
ICR the Rwanda tribunal and so what
again what we've now sort of recognized
is that we need these simultaneous and
sequential transitional justice
mechanisms and also that the hybrid
tribunals the Sierra Leone and Cambodia
actually included as part of their
mandates to much more closely work with
the local jurisdictions in order to
develop their capacities to process
cases as well further criticisms include
that there's been too little
participation by Rwandan in the ICR and
hasn't reflected their interests or even
their laws and so yet again the hybrid
tribunals for Sierra Leone and Cambodia
in particular were designed precisely to
remedy that concern they include staff
from their local jurisdictions and even
laws and legal sensibilities as well the
ICR as I had mentioned was created in
Arusha outside of Rwanda this again that
led to further criticisms that too many
transitional justice mechanisms are
created too far from their sites of
atrocities and so again in response the
hybrid tribunals were created on the
site of their low of their atrocities
the one for Sierra Leone was created in
Sierra Leone the one for Cambodia was
created in Cambodia however you know now
there's criticism that the ICC which is
headquartered in The Hague is now taking
a step back there have been
conversations about possibly opening up
field offices of the ICC in their sites
of investigation and prosecution but it
remains to be seen
there's also been these concerns that if
you create a tribunals as in the case of
Rwanda ex post facto you would lose any
sort of deterrent effect and so again
now the ICC which is a standing
permanent mechanism can can be used
hopefully to promote deterrence I think
we're in the time then okay take two
more minutes you have another criticism
leading to yet further legacies are that
Victor
have not been sufficiently concerned
addressed through the ice DTR
there was virtually no consideration for
how victims should be dealt with and in
direct response to that criticism the
ICC was designed with that concern in
mind and so now has a trust fund for
victims I think I'll skip further and
just mention a few final institutional
legacies for the US government itself
and then all I'll conclude so one is
that the White House instituted it's a
presidential directive pdp-10 which
actually mentions that genocide
prevention should be a core national
security interest and this in many ways
owes its genesis in part to the the
Rwandan genocide the genocide against
the Tutsi it also has developed various
infrastructure in order to try to deal
with these situations in the future and
now has a sort of controversial
atrocities prevention board which too
many has not dealt with Syria as well as
other circumstances sufficiently there
are now other institutions as well
there's now a director on the national
security staff who's mandated with
focusing on war crimes a special envoy
to the region of concern the Department
of Justice and the Department of State
have now also either expanded or
repurposed offices to focus on genocide
and atrocities and has been mentioned
before various leaders various
individuals servants senior capacities
now in the Obama administration invoke
Rwanda often in their decision making
civil society has expanded greatly from
an indirect response to the Ronen
genocide which also is yet another
legacy that's extremely helpful that
said I should mention that as has been
said before
it really is political will which
remains the elusive legacy of the
Rwandan genocide you know we can point
to various normative developments and
even you know institutional and legal
developments as well but especially as
in the case of Syria you know we see
dithering and it remains to be seen I
think whether the call the call to never
again will
mean anything or whether we'll just keep
saying it again and again so thank you
very much